federal air safety investigators say
they found no evidence of engine failure
in Kobe Bryant's deadly helicopter crash
the Lakers legend his 13 year old
daughter Gianna and seven others were
killed when the helicopter went down
into a rocky hillside outside of Los
Angeles Kris Van Cleave has more on the
final moments of the flight it appears
the engines were working that from a new
NTSB report citing evidence the rotors
were still spinning when Kobe Bryant's
helicopter crashed killing all nine
aboard a witness on a mountain bike
trail just 50 feet above the crash site
told the NTSB he saw the helicopter
emerge from the clouds it was moving
fast and descending it rolled to the
left such that he caught a glimpse of
its belly one to two seconds later the
crash he took this picture of the
burning wreckage the NTS b--'s Jennifer
Hamid II last week do you have a sense
if the helicopter came down all in one
piece preliminary information is that
the helicopter was in one piece when it
impacted the terrain a doorbell camera
captured the sound of the chopper flying
overhead just before the crash at about
the same moment this newly released
image from a security camera was taken
it is now the last known picture of the
helicopter as it disappeared into the
clouds about two miles from the crash
site the NTSB now says the pilot told
air traffic controllers he was climbing
to 4,000 feet to get above the clouds he
made it to about 2300 and began a left
turn eight seconds later the helicopter
began to descend then plummet the NTS
b--'s preliminary report does not make
any conclusions the Safety Board's
investigation will likely take up to a
year we are learning some new details
about a public memorial for Kobe Bryant
and the other victims of this crash
February 24th at the Staples Center
where Kobe played as a Laker for CBS
this morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington you know we first got news
about that memorial you saw the two 24:4
Gianna's number and Kobe's number and
Vanessa Bryant even put out a post last
night right yeah it it's just so sad I
know it's it's been a little while now
what a week and a half almost two weeks
it just feels sad and you can't even
imagine number people they're gonna be
both ends
Center and then outside they talked
about taking it to the Colosseum yeah
seeing the morning right away I'm
certain there will be a large crowd
wanting to mourn together